I'm gonna be honest he could be he could  I'm just saying if you're gonna call me  a fascist yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna point  out that so how did how was it when the  cameras weren't rolling with Eli and  crew well before they separated the  conservatives and the lips so like they  put us in different rooms and it was  very like they were kind of they had  people in there and they're like don't  talk about polit like don't talk about  the panel stuff which I understand I do  that too sometimes yeah before shows  I'll be like don't talk about the topic  ah because you want to get it on camera  so I I respect that I understand that  um then we do the panel which is super  long oh my gosh that was so hot too you  know how like sometimes